[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعلوا اخرى البدايه من موسكو التي
استهدفت مسيرته اوكرانيه مواقع عسكريه
حساسه بالقرب منها في تطور لافت ضمن
تداعيات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ومن
نيويورك
للعاصفه الثلجيه التي تهب على مناطق واسعه
من الولايات المتحده وتحدث مزيدا من
الخسائر اخرها في بافلو في ولايه نيويورك
ومن الخرطوم نتابع هذه الصور العاصمه
السودانيه كانت على موعد مع مظاهرات سماها
منظمها مليونيه السادس والعشرين من ديسمبر
دعما للمطالب بمدنيه الحكم
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
لاول مره منذ اندلاع الحرب
مسيره الاوكرانيه تستهدف قاعده تضم قادفات
استراتيجيه جنوب شرق موسكو روسيا تقول ان
الغربه سيضطر للتفاوض واوكرانيا تقول انها
تهدف لعقد قمه سلام النهايه فبراير ويفضل
ان تكون في الامم المتحده
بسبب مناورات صينيه موسعه في محيط تايوان
في منطقه دفاعا الجويه واشنطن تعبر عن
القلق مما سمته النشاط العسكريه الصيني
الاستفزازي قربتايوان وموسكو تعلن قرب
اجراء مباحثات بين الرئيسين الروسي
والصيني
في حادث ان هو الاول من نوعه منذ خمس
سنوات مسيرات كوريا الشماليه تخترق اجواء
اجارتها الجنوبيه وتقترب من العاصمه سول
الجيش الكوري الجنوبي يصف الخطوه
بالاستفزازيه ويرد باطلاق طائرات مسيره
الى بيونغيان
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل يعلن بدء
مشاورات مع قوه في المجتمع المدني لما
سماه انقاد البلاد ويقول انه كان على
الرئيس التقاط الرساله من خلال العزوف
الشعبي عن الانتخابات التشريعيه وسعيد
يعلن ان العمليه الانتخابيه ستتواصل ويتهم
اطرافا لم يسمها باختلاق الازمات ومحاوله
اسقاط الدوله
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه
ناقشنا تصريحات وزيره الماليه التونسيه
التي قالت ان موازنه السنه القادمه والتي
تناهز 54 مليار دينار اما يعادل 22 مليار
و 300 مليون دولار لا تتضمن اجراءات
الموجعه للمواطنين ياتي ذلك في وقت يظهر
فيه قانون الماليه الذي وقعه الرئيس فيس
سعيد ونشر في الجريده الرسميه ان الضرائب
ستشكل اكثر من 87% من مداخيل هذه
الميزانيه الاستطلاعات ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال الثاني
ماذا دعايات ميزانيه العمل مقبل في تونس
على الصعوبات الاقتصاديه التي يعانيها
المواطنون
72% توقعوا ان تكون هناك تداعيات كبيره
وقال سبعه في المئه ان تداعيات الميزانيه
على ظروف المواطن ستكون في حدود مقبوله
بينما قال 21% انه لا تاثير سلبيا لها على
المواطنين هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصات الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت
عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودونيه
وتتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
[موسيقى]
25 قتيلا في منطقه بافلوب بولايه نيويورك
وحدها خسائر جديده جراء اسوء عاصفه ثلجيه
في الولايات المتحده منذ عقود
[موسيقى]
في ما يبدو انه استمرار للمساء الاوكرانيه
لحديثه لنقل المعركه الى داخل روسيا مسيره
اوكرانيه تستهدف قاعده انجلز العسكريه
جنوب شرقي موسكو وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اعلنت احباط الهجوم لكنها قالت ان ثلاثه
من عسكريها قتلوا جراء سقوط الحصان تجدد
المعارك لم يمنع من الحيث عن حتميه الجلوس
الى طاوله التفاوض جاء ذلك على لسان الى
الرفقاء لان الغربه سيفعله في نهايه
المطاف شاء ام ابا في المقابل ترد كيف
بالتاكيد على ان للحرب نهايه وحيده
ولهازيمه من سمته الطرف
تنعطف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا يتغير شكل
القتال لتاخذ القوات الاوكرانيه خطوات
النحو الامان تقصف قاعده للقاذفات الروسيه
بعيده المدى والقديره على حمل رؤوس
النوويه على بعد اكثر من 700 كيلو متر في
العمق عن الحدود تضرب القوات الاوكرانيه
ليست المره الاولى لكن تصريحا من القوات
الاوكرانيه يرفع التوتر بين الجانبين يقول
المتحدث الاوكراني ان الروس مخطئون اذا
اعتقدوا ان الحرب لن تمسهم في العمق ليس
هذا وحسب من جانب واحد هذه المره يعلن
الروس عن قتل من وصف بمجموعه من المخربين
الذين حاولوا التسلل الى مقاطعه بريانس
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا لم يعلق الاوكرانيون
لكن الحدث ان صح التفاصيله فقد يعني ان
القوات الاوكرانيه قررت بالفعل نقل
المعركه الى العمق الروسي كما اشار
المتحدث باسم القوات الاوكراني السابقه
تبدو هذه الانباء الابرز في التطورات
الميدانيه للحرب لكن الميدان داخل الحدود
الاوكرانيه لم يهدا تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه ان نظيرتها الروسيه نفذت خلال
الساعات الماضيه اكثر من 40 هجوما المقابل
تعرض وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعمالا قتاليه
باستخدام نظام دفاع جوي الروسي متخصصا في
اسقاط مسيرات
بعد 10 اشهر من القتال ثم تحديثا ليس
جديدا عن طاوله المفاوضات يقول وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه ان الغربه سيضطر في
نهايه المطاف الى التفاوض مع روسيا
فقد قطعوا تقريبا كل العلاقات
تصريحاته وان كانت لنظره حاده فانها بوضوح
الى التفاوض لذلك امر لفت النظر اليها
الرئيس الروسي عندما قال ان كل النزاعات
تنتهي بالتفاوض متهما اوكرانيا والغرب
برفض الدخول في هذا المسار الاخرانيون
يتحدثون بلغه اخرى تقول الرئاسه هناك كان
للحرب نهايه واحده هي هزيمه المعتدي
ومعاقبته بقسوه
ومع ذلك يجب ان يكون جاهزين لاي
سيناريوه
قد تكون بينها نهايه هذه الحرب بالجلوس
الى طاوله واحده او استمرار القتال اكثر
واكثر هي من قليله قبل بدايه عام جديد
واسابيع قليله كذلك قبل ان تطوي هذه الحرب
عامها الاول
عن وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني ديمتري كوليبا
قوله ان الحكومه الاوكرانيه تهدف الى عقد
قمه سلام بحلول نهايه شهر شباط فبراير
المقبل وانه يفضل ان تكون في الامم
المتحده مع الامين العام انطونيو جوتيرش
كوسيط المحتمل وفقا تعبيره كما قال كليب
بين جميع الحروب التي تنتهي بطريقه هندسيه
وتكون نتيجه التطورات في ميدان المعارك
والحوار على طاوله المفاوضات حسب تعبيره
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا دخلت شارع الحادي
عشر وقد تارجح اداء الجيش الروسي خلالها
بين التقدم والتراجع وارجع خبراء في روسيا
ضعف الاداء في محطات كثيره الى ضعف تقييم
امكانيات الجيش الاوكراني وتزايد الدعم
الغربي
كانت هذه الصواريخ البالستيه حتى الامس
القريب عامله سوفياتي امام تهديدات بحرب
كادت تندلعوا بين المعسرين الغربي والشرقي
تختلف اليوم الظروف والسياقات في خضم حرب
مستعره في اوكرانيا
بوقوع اصطدام النووي
لم يكن اكثر الخبراء درايه بسياسه
الخارجيه لروسيا يتوقعوا قبل النحو عام من
الان ان تشون موسكو ما تطلق عليه عمليه
عسكريه في اوكرانيا
والى حد السخريه احيانا نيتهم اجتياح
الجاره الغربيه جغرافيا
والمتزايد ميلها نحو الغربي ايديولوجيا
وسياسيا وعسكريا بعد يومين من اعترافه
باستقلال جمهوريتين
عن اوكرانيا
فجر الرابع والعشرين من فبراير شباط عمليه
عسكريه لتحقيق اهداف من بينها نزع سلاح
اوكرانيا
طلبت فيها بالحصول على ضمانه نمليه من
بينها التعاهد بعدم انضمامك الى حلف
النيته
مقترحات ووجهت بالرفض وهو من بين ما بررت
به موسكو حينئذ لجوءها الى القوه منذ
اليوم الاول لتدخل العسكري تارجح اداء
الجيش الروسي والفصائل المواليه له بين
التقدم الكاس حجاره
وتراجع الموجع تاره اخرى وهو مارجعتهم
موسكو لاسباب من بينها تزايد الدعم الغربي
لكيف والحاجه الى تعزيز عدد القوات وهو ما
دفع بوتين لاعلان عمليه تعبئه جزئيه شملت
300,000 شخص واظهرت عيوبه تنظيميه كثيره
وكان من تداعيتها فرار عشرات الالاف الى
خارج البلاد هربا من التعبئه
تم تسريحه القوات الاوكرانيه وتدريبها
بشكل صحيح بصراحه
القياده العسكريه اليوم تواصلت الى
استنتاجات ومع التعبئه الجزئيه ستتغير
الامور لمصلحه قريبا العقوبه اكثر سلاحا
استخدمه الغرب ضد موسكو منذ ان اطلقت
عمليتها العسكريه
ادفرض عليها اكثر من ثمانيه الاف 1500
اجراء من خلال المؤشرات الاقتصاديه يبدو
ان موسكو استطاعته الى حد معين احتواء
الصدمه والتعايش مع طبيعتها
الاقتصاد الروسي والمجتمع تعايش بسرعه مع
الواقع الجديد لكن هذا لا يخفي وجود مشاكل
من بينها مغادره عدد كبير من المواطنين
الى الخارج لاسباب مختلفه تفرض على روسيا
الان الحزمه التاسعه من العقوبات لكنها
سيكون اضعف نتيجه تكيف في الاقتصاد مع
القيود ضمه روسيه
اثار الجدل ولم يحضر اعتراف دولي
خطوه شكلت لحظه سياسيه فارقه في الصراع
رغم انها لم تؤثر على الوضع الميداني
المتارجح بين التصعيد
وضعنا يتوقف المنح الذي سيسلكه العام
المقبل في راي كثيرين على حسابات كل طرف
وان غابت اي بوادر لتسويه الصراع في
المستقبل المنظور على الاقل
كبيره المستشارين بوزاره الخارجيه السلفيه
سيد متر ابدا
سؤال لك هو كيف ترى موسكو كيف ترى روسي
هذا الهجوم الاوكراني في العمق
الاستراتيجي هذه المره بالقرب من العاصمه
الروسيه ولا نتحدث عن هجوم عن عن في
الاطراف
طبيعه الحال هذه هذه الضربه
الحساسيه لان مسيره سياتيه قديمه استخدمت
ولكن من الواضح ان اوكرانيا
وخلفائها في الغرب حدثوا من تلك المسيره
والمسيره الباليه السابقه لم تكن لتصل الى
العمق الروسي وتقطع الاف الاميال وهذا ما
قامت به المسيره وبالتالي هذا
امر يثيره الامتعاضه ولكنكم لم يلحق الضرر
باي طائره ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا نعم هذه
ماساه ولكن هذا لن يرضع روسيا من
استمرارها في خوض العمليه على العموم
نور هذه الحربه ماساه من جهه نظر الروسي
وما من احد سعيد بشان استهدافه البنيه
التحتيه الكهربائيه وبنيه الطاقه في
اوكرانيا لدينا اقرباء هناك واصدقاء في
اوكرانيا ولكن هذا رد على مثل هذه الضربات
بما في ذلك استهدافه الجسر في القرنه انما
حاول الاوكرانيون ان يقطعه الكهرباء على
شبه جزيره القرد وبالتالي ان المزاج في
موسكو ليس سيئا رغم كل المشاكل المستوى
العيش لم ينخفض عن احمد اذا ما اتيت الى
موسكو فانك سوف ترى موسكو كما كانت عليه
وشركات الغربيه التي رحلت لم تغير شيئا ان
الشركات الروسيه حللت بحلها لذلك همم
ونشربه الكولا نفسها ولكن ليس هناك اسم
كولا على القاروره
اذا سمحت لي اريد ان اذهب لان السيد همم
مزيكاروف هذا هجوم من هذا النوع كيف يمكن
قراءته في سياق تصريحات لوزير خارجيه
الاوكراني الذي يتحدث الان عن همم ان
اوكرانيا تهدف الى عقد قمه سلام بحلول شهر
فبراير المقبل
والحلفاء الغربيين لانهم سوف يدافعون عن
اوكرانيا
والرئيسكي راسي اخوه القدمين ولم
يستسلمكم الحرب
تنتهي الا اذا ما هزم
المعتدي وهذا هو الخط الذي سوف تتبعه
اوكرانيا وسوف تدعمه من قبل الحلفاء
الغربيين على طول الخط لذلك
اوكرانيا سوف يتم ارهابها على تقديم
تنازلات
ستيك
انني اعتقد انه لم يكن ثمه بوادر من هذا
القبيل لذلك اعتقد ان اوكراني سوف تحظى
بدعم من الغرب
ويحدون الامل النص هنا الى حل الدبلوماسي
لان هذا النزاع عام يزهق الارواح وهذه هي
كارثه انسانيه ايضا
واقتصاديه وتؤثر اقتصاديا على الكثير من
الدول الى العالم وتلحق الضرر بالكثير
منها نعم
هل يمكن لروسيا ان تقبل قمه سلامته عقد في
الامم المتحده وبساطه
كما يشير اليه وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
راشن فور يمين
الخارجيه الروسيه الشرقيه اليوم
عبر عن تقييمه لما ذكر وقال ان السلام يجب
ان يكون قائما على التنازلات ولكن ما
سمعناه من الرئيس زيريسكي منذ ايام هو ان
هذا السلام لن يمر من خلال التناسلات لذلك
سيدسكي من واضح انه ينظر الى السلام
العادل من خلال الانتصار
واسترداد
الدمبرز
بعد
سنوات
وهو ايضا يريد شبه زيت القرن لتعود الى
اوكرانيا
اثنين مليون من القويه الروسيه هذا طبعا
لن يحصل السيد الافريق قال ذلك وبحزم
واعتقد انه
قد تماما مع الرئيس بوتن الذي قال
اليوم
ان الغرب اا يطلق الحرب
ضدنا من خلال قاعده فرق تسد والغرب
دق اسفينا بيننا وبين اوكرانيا ولكن الان
نرى هذه الاستراتيجيه بوضوح ولن نغبن مره
اخرى ونحن لن نؤمن بما تقبوا به ما يقوم
به الغرب حيث يعدنا بوجود اوروبا موحده
روسيا من ضمنها لان انا شاهدنا العقوبات
وشهدنا ما قام به الغرب
والعقوباته الغربيه والضغوطات الغربيه لن
تؤثر على روسيا لسبب
ذلك همم
انا اريد ان اسال اريد ان اسال السيد
مزكرفه هذا بالنسبه لروسيا ولكن ماذا عن
جيران اوكرانيا من حلفائها كيف اثرت
الحرب وماذا كانت داعياتها السياسيه
والاقتصاديه لهذه الحرب التي استمرت احد
10 شهرا وطال وقتها
الشرقيه واوروبا الوسطى ووقعوا ذلك طبعا
كبير حيث هربت رؤوس الاموال والاصول الى
ملذات امنه وهذا طبعا اثر على العملات
التي انخفضت قيمتها على نحو الحاده التضخم
بطبعه الحال وصل الى اكثر من 10% مدفوعه
بتضخم الخاص بموارد الطاقه والمواد الخام
التي كانت تاتينا من اوكرانيا وروسيا عن
احمد منتظم
المصرف المركزيه عنه كثيرا في مقاومتها
لاتضخم هذه السبب الصدمات التي لحقت
الموردين
وكانت هناك طبعا امور اخرى اقتصاديه
مرتبطه باسلوبي المعيشه في المجر
وبالغاريا وطولندا مملكه تضخم من قد وصل
عنانه السبى مقارنه مع اي دوله اخرى
بالاضافه الى ذلك هنالك مشاكل مرتبطه
بالصوره القاطمه الخاصه بالصناعات
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك من بره الاسلام سوف
موزيك روفا كبيره المستشارين في وزاره
الخارجيه سوفيه
[موسيقى]
من النفط حوالي 11 مليون برميل يوميا يصدر
نصفها تقريبا لتحتل المرتبه السابعه
عالميا من حيث احتياطات النفط بالنسبه 25
من المئه من الاحتياط العالمي انتجت روسيا
العمل الماضي اكثر من 500 مليون طن من
النصف اي اكثر من ثلاثه مليارات و600
مليون
ينتظروا ان ينخفض هذا الانتاج هذا العام
بنسبه تتراوح ما بين خمسه في المئه»
وعلى صعيد الغاز تتربع روسيا على راس
قائمه منتجه الغاز الطبيعي في العالم
وتستخرج يوميا مليارا و800 مليون متر مكعب
اما احتياطاته روسيا من الغاز ستقدر باكثر
من 74 مليون متر مكعب من الموارد القابله
للاستخراج وحوالي 290 مليون متر مكعب من
الموارد المتعه وتلك كميه
لقد انها ستكون كافيه ل 80 او 100 عام من
الانتاج اليومي عام 2021 صدرت روسيا اكثر
من 200 مليار متر مكعب من الغاز ذهبت
اغلبيتها الساحقه الى اوروبا ودولي اسيا
الوسطى
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه ان 47 طائره
حربيه صينيه اخترقت منطقه تحديد الدفاع
الجوي للجزيره وهذا هو اكبر تورغل جوي
يومي يسجل حتى الان واوضح حتى ان احدى
وسبعين طائره شاركت في هذه المناورات
الصينيه بالاضافه الى سبع سفن وتاتي هذه
المناورات في وقت شهدت فيه المنطقه تصعيدا
وتزايدا منذ بدايه
اصبحت المناوره العسكريه اسلوب الصين
المفضله للرد على ما تعتبره استفزازات
الولايات المتحده وسلطات جزيره تايوان ما
يميز هذه المناوره انها تخترق في الغالب
منطقه الدفاع الجوي للجزيره وهذه المنطقه
التي تحددها دول منها تايوان لا تتطابق مع
المجال الجوي بل تشمل مساحه اكبر ويطلب من
كل طائره اجنبيه تحلق داخلها التعريف
بنفسها تقول وزاره الدفاع تايوانيه ان
الصين نشرت في هذه المناورات احدى و70
طائره حربيه منها 60 مطارده كما نشرت سبع
سفن حربيه وتوضح الوزاره ان سبع واربعين
طائره اخترقت منطقه تحديد الدفاع الجوي
للجزيره وهذا اكبر توهر جوي يومي يسجل حتى
الان حسب وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه يشير
حجم التوغل في الغالب الى درجه غضب
السلطات الصينيه وسبب الغضب بهذه المره
وتبني نصف تشريعيه الامريكيه بشان الدفاع
هو قانون وتفويض الدفاع الوطني الذي يسمح
بمساعدات عسكريه ومبيعات اسلحه امريكيه
للتايوان بقيمه 10 مليارات دولار قبل
المناورات عبرت الخارجيه الصينيه عن
معارضتها الشديده لتبني هذا النص التشريعي
لانه من وجهه نظرها يعد تدخل في شان صيني
فبجين تعتبر تايوان جزءا من التراب الصيني
تعرف الصين ان الضغط العسكري اقوى من
عبارات التمديد الدبلوماسيه ولذلك فقد
كشفت هذه السنه من التحليق فوق منطقه
الدفاع الجوي لطايوان تم تسجيله 10,700
عمليا من هذا النوع هذه السنه مقارنه مع
160 عمليه فقط خلال 2020 يشير الفرق بين
الرقمين الى حجم التصعيد الذي شهده في
تايوان هذه السنه هو الذي ترافق مع حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا فقد زادت واشنطن من
دعمها لتايوان وزاره رئيسته مجلس النواب
الامريكي
الجزيره رغم اعتراضي بيج
وردت الصين بتكثيف مناوراتها واجراء
مناورات مشتركه مع روسيا في بحر جنوب
الصين وكذا بتكثيف الاتصالات بين قائدي
البلدين ومنها مباحثات قالت طاش ان الرئيس
بعد نمر بوتين سيجريها مع رئيس الصين شيجي
بينك قبل نهايه السنه وتبدو هذه التحركاتك
رسائل من واشنطن التي تريد الحفاظ على
الوضع كما هو في تايوان والصين التي تريد
ضم الجزيره يوما ما سلبيا كما تقول لكن
دون استبعاد استخدام القوه
قال متحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي في هذه الاسماء ان الولايات
المتحده تشعر بالقلق اذا ما وصفه بالنشاط
العسكري الاستفزازي للصين بالقرب من
تايوان واضاف ان النشاط العسكريه الصيني
يزعزع الاستقرار ويخاطر بالوقوع في حسابات
خاطئه ويقوض السلامه والاستقرار
الاقليميين واوضح ان لدى الولايات المتحده
مصلحه ثابته في السلام والاستقرار عبر
مضيق تايوان واكد ان الاداره الامريكيه
ستستمر في تقديم الدعم لتايوان لتحافظ على
القدره الكافيه للدفاع عن نفسها بما
يتماشى مع التزاماتها طويله الامد وبما
يتفق مع سياسه الصين الواحده
معنا من روم وجوليو بوليسي الخبير في
الشؤون الصينيه في جامعه اوكسفورد اريد ان
تساعدنا على فهم تلك الجمله الاخيره
للمتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
الذي قال ان الولايات المتحده ستستمر في
الدعم العسكري لتايوان لتحافظ على قدرتها
الدفاعيه بما يتماشى مع الالتزام بالصين
الواحده ما الذي يعنيه ذلك لان الصينيين
يقولون اذا كانت اذا كان هذا ما تؤمنون به
وتقرون به فما شانكم بتيوان دعوها وشانها
فهي جزء من الصين الواحد
بس اذا
الكويشن
للغايه
وهو مرتبط
بالتفاصيل
والدول السبعه يعني بذلك سياسه الصين
الواحد المختلفه عما يسمى مبدا السيد
الواحده في واقعه الان الوقت فتحت
الامريكيه تعترفه
الصين الذي يقول
هي جزء منها على الحكومه الامريكيه
تعترفوا بهذا الموقف ولكنها لا تقبله
بالضروره وبالتالي هنا تكبر الضبابيه
على ما هو عليه ضمان
استقلال تايوان وفقا للامر الواقع تايوان
طبعا جزء من سلسله الجزر التي
تنطلق من اليابان والفلبين واندونيسيا
ومضيق مالقه
وصول الى درع ربما توسع الصين في المحيط
الهادئ لذلك الوقت بتحيه تريد هذه الدول
التي التي هي الجزر او سلسله من الجزر
لتعززا من قدراتها صواريخ الصواريخ
البالستيه
وايضا صبرها الاخرى لكي ترد
او احتمال عدوانها
في اعتقادك مع حدود هذا التصعيد من الصين
هل يمكن ان تلجا لضم تايوان بالقوه
العسكريه
قدراته الصين العسكري يمكن ان تقلب
الموازين لصالحها لان تايوان قريبه منها
كما نعرفها ولكن سياسيا
واقتصاديا في واقع الامر هذا سوف يكون
هدفا غير مرجح اذا
اراده
الغرب بين قوسين قد اظهروا الوحده في فرضه
عقوبته على روسيا بعد اعتدائها على اوكرا
عليها وصدقني
الصين
واستفادت مما جرس هيما وحده الغرب مع
اليابان واستراليا هذه يمكن انه تنسى في
حالته تايوان والحزب الشيوعي الصيني
والشرعيته قائمه
قال روحي الوطنيه وايضا الاداء الاقتصاديه
في هذه المرحله
همم
يعاني من سياسه الكوفت الصفريه لذلك
الكثير من المشاكل
المحليه التي يتصارع معها
بالاضافه الى ذلك
قوته وطنيه في الصين يريد ان يسترضها من
دون ان يقدم اشياء ذات جوهر شكرا جزيلا
لكم
الخبير في الشؤون الصينيه في جامعه
[موسيقى]
قالت وكاله الانباء في الشغل ان الجيش
كوريا الجنوبيه اخفق في اسقاط طائرات
مسيره لكوريا الشماليه اخترقت اجواء
البلاد ووصلت حتى العاصمه بينما لم تعلق
على الحادث نجحت سول ان الاختراق كان بغرض
التجسس هذا اول خلق للمجال الجوي الكوري
الجنوبي منذ خمس سنوات وياتي في سياق توتر
شديد بعد زياده كوريا الشماليه
تصعيد جديد في شبه الجزيره الكوريه لعله
الاخطر منذ خمسه اعوام فهذه مسيرات تجتاز
خط الهدنه الحدودي وتخترق المجال الجويه
لكوريا الجنوبيه تتوغل المسيارته اكثر
فتقترب من العاصمه سول تطلق المضادات
الارضيه نيرانها لكنها لا تسقط اي من
الطائرات المغيره وعددها خمسه وفق وزاره
دفاع الجزء الجنوبي التي اكدت ايضا ان
جيشها حرك مقاتلات ومروحيات الى المنطقه
لتعقب المسيارات الشماليه
ولاحقا اعلنت صول ان احدى مقاتلاتها
المشاركه في تلك المهمه وهي من طراز كي اي
1 تحطمت في موقع طاعتهم سونج شرق البلاد
الاختراق الجوي ادى ايضا الى اربك حركه
الملاحه الجويه في صول فبناءا على طلب
الجيش تم تعليق الرحلات لنحو ساعه في
مطاري جامبو وانشون الدوليين قرب العاصمه
اذا كل هذه التطورات لاذت بيونغ يانغ
بالصمت بينما قللت سول من قدره تلك
المسيارات على اي فعل هجومي مرجحه قدومها
لاغراض الاستكشاف والتجسس
وبصرف النظر عن واجهه ذلك الاحتمال فان
التوغل الجديد في المجال الجوي الكوري
الجنوبي يشكل اختبارا صعبا لما يمكن
تسميته سياسه حافه الهاويه التي يتبعها
الجزء الشمالي فهي قد تؤدي في اي لحظه الى
الاسوا بين الكوريتين بعد نحو 70 عاما على
انتهاء الحرب الطاحنه بينهما
وقد شهد العام الحالي مستويات تصعيد قياسي
اذ اجرت بيونغيان سلسله تجارب على الاسلحه
كان اهمها لاختبار اقوى صاروخ بالستي عابر
للقارات
كما اطلقت الاسبوع الماضي صاروخين بالستين
قصيري المدى ورد على ذلك اجر جيش كوريا
الجنوبيه تدريبات عسكريه واسعه النطاق مع
القوات الامريكيه المرابطه هناك والتي
يبلغ قوامها
28,000
و500 جندي
الباحث المختصر في شؤون شبه جزيره الكوريه
والعلاقات الدوليه في شرق اسيا اهلا وسهلا
بك ما حدود هذا التصعيد بين
الكوريتين بعد سبعين عاما من حاله لا حرب
و ااا الى حرب ولا سلم
شكرا على الاستضافه اعتقد انه في عالمي
رئيس هيئه الاركان حسب كلماته في قريه
جنوبيه على الحادث ان الجيش كوريا
الجنوبيه ردوا بشكل كامل هذا هو الجواب
المعتاد
تجاهزات كوريا الشماليه هذا العام في
السنوات الماضيه نعم انك مرت سبعون عاما
تقريبا
في هذه النتيجه غير الانهائيه بعد الحرب
الكوريه ما يعني هذا الامر اعتقد اولا ان
هذا الامر
ينص على ان يتم
مصمم على همم اكمالي قائمه مشترياته في
تعزيزي امكانياته في الاسلحه التقليديه
وغير التقليديه التي شرحها بشكل ان كامل
في مؤتمر الثامن
للحزب في عام 2021 يتحدث عن صواريخ
بالستيه مختلفه وايضا تحدث عن اسلحه
مختلفه ضمنها مسيرات وبضمنها
مسيرات هجوميه وسيارات لا عمليات
الاستطلاع ما يظهروا هذا الامر اننا نصل
الى مرحله تكون فيها كوريا الشماليه همم
تقوم هذه خطوات فعاله من اجل تحديث
وتنويعه وتوسيع همم ادواتها المتوفره
والمتاحه لها بالنسبه للاسلحه هل يمكن ان
يكون هناك صدام عسكري كما ذكرت بعد 70
عاما من توقفه هل هناك ظروف حاليا يمكن ان
تؤدي الى ذلك
اعتقد ان علينا
جدا في
القيامه باصدار تصريحات اذا ما كان هنالك
حرب كوريه اخرى ام لا كان هنالك عده
مناسبات في تاريخ التسعينيات مثلا عندما
قامت الولايات المتحده
كانت هنالك همم كانت افضل امكانيات لانويه
لكوريا الشماليه في ذلك الوقت
المتطوره تماما
مدى امكانيات الكامله لكوريا الشماليه قد
تمتلك الف مسيره مثلا بعضها قد يكون لديها
امكانيات استطلاع ايضا باعت قلق اضافي
يتمثل بامكانيه هذه المسيرات على حملي
اسلحه كيميائيه وبايولوجيه ونحن نعرف ان
كوريا الشماليه
وقد قامت بتطوير اسلحتنا بايلوجيه
وكيميائيه ارغب فقط بالاضافه بالقول بان
هذه ليست المره الاولى التي استخدمت فيها
كوريا الشماليه مسيراتها ضد كوريا
الجنوبيه راينا حادثا قبل خمس سنوات في
عام 2017 عندما كانت مسيره لكوريا
الشماليه عبره الحدود في محاوله لالتقاط
الصور
لانظمه الدفاع المدني الصواريخ في سؤال
شكرا جزيلا لك
الباحه المختص في شؤون شبه الجزيره
الكوريه ولا علاقات الدوليه في شرق اسيا
في تونس اعلن الامين العام الاتحاد
التونسي للشغل نور الدين الطبول ان
الاتحاد بدا مشاورات مع عميد المحامين
والرابطه التونسيه للدفاع عن حقوق الانسان
من اجل بلوره تصور لمبادره مع منظمات وقوى
المجتمع المدني لانقاذ البلاد واضاف
الطبوبي انه لو كانت هناك رجاحه عقل سياسي
وحمكه لدى اصحاب القرار لكان الرئيس قيس
سعيد قد التقط رساله الشعب من خلال نسب
العزوفه عن المشاركه في الدوري الاول من
الانتخابات التشريعيه
نجاح اتمنى العقل السياسي
والحنك السياسيه اني السيد رئيس الجمهوريه
لو قال ان الرساله وصلت من الشعب التونسي
والتقطته اللحظه
من الوراء من اجل الاصلاح
وكان رئيس التونسيه اكد ان العمليه
الانتخابيه ستتواصل ان الشعب سيقول كلمته
في الانتخابات واتهم سعيد اطرافا لم يسمها
باختلاق الازمات ومحاوله اسقاط الدوله على
حد تعبيره
الشعب يعرفهم وعلى كل من يقوموا على هذه
الانتخابات
وكل من يراقبها في القضاء ان ينتبها الى
هؤلاء الذين امتوا تحت اوزان مختلفه وبي
لباس مختلف حتى يفسد العمليه الانتخابيه
العربيه العمليه الانتخابيه
ستتواصل وسيقول الشعب كريبته ثم امكانيه
سحب الوكاله من هؤلاء الذين لم دسوا وارده
في نص الدستور
معنى من تونس بالحسن اليحياوي الكاتب
المحلل السياسي من تونس ايضا جوهر بن
مبارك القيادي في الجبهه في جبهه الاخلاص
الوطني اهلا وسهلا بكما ابدا منك سيد
بالحسن السيد نور الدين الطبوق بالامين
العام للاتحاد الشغل يقول ان الرئيس سعيد
كان عليه ان يلتقط الرساله رساله
المواطنين والشعب التونسي من عزوفهم عن
الانتخابات
هل عليه ان يلتقطها ايضا من هذه المبادره
مبادره انقاذ تونس التي اعلن عنها نور
الدين الطبوبي هو يقول ااه يعني بشكل واضح
الوقت انتهى ولن نقفه مكتوب في العيد
نعم هو في الحقيقه يعني الاتحاد العام
اتحدث عقبه الخامس والعشرين من جويليه 21
واساسا بعد اصدار مرسوم 117
او خيار ثالث هذا الخيار طبعا يقطعه مع
مصطلح حاله
تراجع عن هذا الخيار
وبقي موقفه من رئيس الجمهوريه ليخرج
عمره اخرى والان طبعا من الطبيعي ان اذا
لم يتقط رئيس الصعيد الرساله التي وجهها
له تونسيون من خلال نسبه العجول في
المرتفعه جدا في الانتخابات التشريعيه
يبدو ان الاتحاد الشغل التقط هذه الرساله
وهمم ربما يرى انه بامكانه ان يقدمه حنا
بديلا تونسيين حلا يرضي اولئك الغاضبين من
منظومه الرابعه والعشرين من جويليه والغير
عفوا السيد بن حسن سؤال هو ان الرئيس متهم
بانه لا يحاور احد يعني وهذا كلام قاله
حتى السيد الطبوبي انه دائما يقول انه
يتشاور في موضوع الاقتصاد مثلا صندوق
النقد مع الاطراف المجتمعيه واتحاد الشغل
تحديدا
وبصريح العباره قال كفى كذبا لان هذا لا
يحدث اذا كيف يمكن لهذا ان يتم دون ان
يكون حوار بين الرئيس والاخرين
نعم اذا كنا نتحدث عن قدرات الرئيس مع
مختلف الكائنات السياسيه والمجتماعيه في
يبدو ان اتحاد الشغل هو الاقل اصابه بهذا
الاسم
قله محاولته لبقيه الاطراف الا انه كان
هناك حوار وان لم يكن بطريقه مباشره
اتحاد الشغل كان منظمه هو الاقرب الى رئيس
الجمهوريه
في حوارنا هذا السيد جوهر ما فرص مبادره
من هذا النوع يمكن ان يطلقها اتحاد الشغل
ويقول انه يقوم بمشاورات بشانها
طلق يعني هناك تطورات كثيره يعني بدات
تبرز في موقف الاتحاد في الاسابيع القليله
الماضيه وخاصه بعد صدور نتائج الانتخابات
المهزله التي وقعت في 17 ديسمبر اعتقد انه
تطور ايجابي وان كان متاخرا وان كان
الاتحاد كان من المفروض ان يكون في ساعه
القوى المدافعه على الديمقراطيه والمناهضه
للانقلابات والمناهضه للاستبداد والحكم
الفردي الاتحاد اخذ حيزا زمانيا طويلا حتى
يستفيق من الغفوه التي ضربته
هل هل يمكن ان تنجح في ظل انقسام واضح
موجود في همم في المعارضه التونسيه
انا لا اعتقد انها سرديه الانقسام هذه
صارت هي ايضا سرديه مزعجه لانه ليس هناك
في الواقع انقسام
كبير الان في المشهد السياسي التونسي هناك
فعلا عجز على التنسيق المشترك والعمل
المشترك ميدانيا ولكن هناك وحده موقف الان
في تونس ولك موقف وطني تقريبا حوله اجماع
لكل المؤسسات المدنيه والسياسيه
والتقريبا النخبه تونس وجزء كبير ايضا من
الشعب وهذا اثبت في الانتخابات الاخيره
صارت لها موقف واضح بان سعيد يقود البلاد
في الطريق الخطا
اذا سمحت يعني
بقيت دقيقتين دقيقه لكل منكم السيد بالحسن
المصاحب الاقتصاديه التي يعرفها الجميع
وقد تحدث وزير الاقتصاد انها سوف تكون
صعبه على المواطنه التونسيين في السنه الى
هل ستجبر الاطراف السياسيه وعلى راسهم
الرئيس السعيد
للتوجه لمبادره من هذا النوع اعلن عنها
الاتحاد التونسي للشغل
هو ليكون واضحين مبادره اتحاد الشغل حتما
لا تسد في صالح المعارضه البرلمانيه ولكنه
ايضا في صالح الرئيس سعيد بما انه يريد
القطع مع كلتها طرفين المصائب الاقتصاديه
هي التي ستمثل فختا هائلا خاصتا على من
يسرق الكهرباء السياسي اي اساسا الرئيس
سعيد وللاسف ما شاهدناه من قانون الماليه
الذي وقعوا تقديمه ليس هناك في هذا
القانون المؤشرات على انه هناك فهم عميق
لاسباب الازمه الاقتصاديه او محاوله اصلاح
بعض الخروج الموجوده في عجله التنميه او
في الاقتصاد التونسي
قدم سوف يشدد الضغط على الرئيس السابق
دقيقه واحده لم نستمع الى تعليقك سيد جوهر
بن مبارك
انا لا اعتقد ان قيس عيد ااا ينتبه الى
مثل هذه المبادرات قيس سعيد شخص مهوس
بالسلطه ومهموس بذاته ويعتبر انه مالك
مطلق للحقيقه وانه مخلص لهذا الشعب
التونسي اعتقد ان الاتحاد الان ينضم الى
مسار وطني انطلق منذ اشهر ومنذ اكثر من
عام عندما خرجت مبادره مواطنون ضد
الانقلاب
وقامت بتحريك الشارع وتحريك ضمائر
التونسيين والتونسيات والتحقق ركبها بعد
ذلك تقريبا كل المشهد السياسي والمدني
التحق الان الاتحاد سيلعب دورا اكيد مع
منظمات المجتمع المدني من اجل تجميع الصف
همم الوطني واعتقد ان الدائره الان همم
اغلقت على قيس سعيد ولكن لا يعني هذا
نهايه المعركه مع الانقلاب نهايه المعركه
ستكون نهائيا ميدانيه وتنطلق عندما يتم
فرض اا ضبط تاريخ الانتخابات الرئاسيه
مبكرا شكرا جزيلا من تونس جوهر بن مبارك
القيادي في جبهه الخلاص ومن تونس ايضا
بالحسن الحيوي والكاتب والمحلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
امر الرئيس الصربيه
بالتوجه الى الحدود مع كوسوفو وفق ما
اعلنه قائد الجيش العربي ياتي هذا الاجراء
واستتفاقم التوتر بين البلدين مؤخرا على
خلفيه منع حركه العبور عند نقاط حدوديه
في فقره المتابعه ستكون لنا وقفه عند
التوتر المتجدد في كوسوفو اسبابه وسياقات
وهو فرص الخروج
في الولايات المتحده ارتفع عدد من اللقب
حدفهم من ضحايا عاصفه الثلجيه غير
المسبوقه منذ عقود الى 48 وذلك بعد اعلان
ولايه نيويورك ارتفاع عدد ضحايا في مدينه
الى 25 دقيقه
متجمدين من البرد في سياراتهم ومنازلهم في
حين لقيا اخرون حتى عبد الرؤى اصابتهم
بازمات قلبيه خلال ازالتهم الثلوج من امام
منازلهم وحول سياراتهم ادت العاصفه الى
الغاء خمسه عشر الف رحله جويه خلال الايام
الاخيره وانقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن اكثر
من مليون شخص واغلاق عدد كبير من الطرق
وتوقعات خدماته الارصاد الجويه تساقط
المزيد من الثلوج اليوم في مناطق الغرب
الاوسط
وقال رئيس مقاطعه اريبي ولايه نيويورك من
معظم الشوارع مدينه بافلو لا تزال ومغلقه
مشيرا الى ان جهود السلطات المحليه تتركز
على فتح طرقات المحيطه بالمستشفيات ودور
رعايه المسنين
من رفع حضر قياده السيارات في بعض المناطق
لكنه مستمر في مدينه بافالو التي لا تزال
معظموا طرقها مغلقه خصوصا الشوارع
الثانويه والجانبيه ويرجعوا ذلك الى ان
جهودنا تركز في المقام الاول على فتح
الطرق حول المستشفيات ودوري رعايه المسنين
السيارات المتروكه في شوارع المدينه وهناك
سيارات في كل مكان
قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
بلاده ستتخذ خطوات جديده لسد ما وصفه
بالثغرات في خطها الامنيه البالغ عمقه 30
كم في سوريا واضاف اردوغان في مؤتمر صحفيه
انقره ستكافح المصادر التي تتعاون مع سماه
التنظيمات الارهابيه
ضد الارهاب الانفصالي في العام الحالي الى
142,000 عمليه كما هدمنا نحو
9800 مخبا للتنظيمات الانفصاليه قمنا
بعمليات عسكريه عابره للحدود هي الاوسع
حتى الان ونتيجه لعمليات المخلب العسكريه
منعا للارهابيون من التسلل الى بلادنا عبر
الحدود العراق
وسنفتح صفحه جديده في مكافحه المصادر التي
تعين التنظيمات الارهابيه وبنيتها التحتيه
نعود لكم الصفوف التوتر المتصاعد بين
بلغراد وبرستينا ليس وليد اليوم والاحداث
الاخيره اججت خلافا قائما منذ عقود ومع
توجه قائد الجيش الصربي الى الحدود
الخلافه الاخير بين الطرفين عندما حددت
كوسوفو الثامنه عشر من ديسمبر كانون الاول
الجري موعدا لاجراء انتخابات في بلديات
ذات اغلبيه لكن الحزب السياسيه الصربيه
الرئيسيه على مقاطعه لاحقا
قبضت سلطاته سابق في ضلوعه في هجمات ضد
ضباط الشرطه من الاغلبيه الالبانيه وفي
العاشر من ديسمبر قام مئات من صربي كوسوفو
باغلاق الطرق في مناطق شمال البلاد
احتجاجا على اعتقال الشرطي وهو ما ادى
لشال لحركه المرور عندما عبرين حدوديه في
نوفمبر اضرب مئات من ابناء الاقليه
الصربيه في شرطه كوسوفو بالاضافه الى قضاه
ومدعينا عامين وغيرهم من العمال احتجاجا
على قرار منع الصرب الذين يعيشون في
كوسوفو من وضع لوحات ترقيم صربيا على
سياراتهم
عوده ملف كسوفو صربيا الى الواجهه مرتبطه
بازمات سابقه لم تحل نهائيا كما ترتبط
بتصاعد النزعه اليمنيه القوميه في صربيا
خلال السنوات الاخيره للتذكير
اقليم كوسوفو الذي يقتله نحو 92 في المئه
من الالبان استقلاله في صربيا عام 2008
لكن بلغرات ترفض الاعتراف به وتتهمه
120 الف صربيا يعيشون في كوسوفو على تحدي
سلطات البلاد في عام 2011 دخل الشرطه
كوسوفو اربع قرى اغلبيه سكانها من الصرب
بهدف السيطره على المعابر الحدوديه بين
كوسوفو وصربيا ونتج عن هذا التدخل
اشتباكات المسلحه وبدات بلغراد منذ ذلك
التاريخ
بالترويش لفكره امكانيه انضمام الجزء
الشمالي من كوسوفو الى جمهوريه صربيا حاول
الاتحاد الاوروبي منذ 2013
حل الخلافات العالقه بين الجانبين عبر
سلسله من جولات التفاوض لكن لم تسفر هذه
المحاولات عن اي تقدم
ويتولى نحو 3760 جندي من قوات حلف الاطلسي
الحفاظ على السلام الحج ضمن قوه يطلق
عليها اختصارا اسم كفوره
من واشنطن ينضم الينا الدكتور ادوارد
جوزيف المدير التنفيذي لمعهد الشؤون
الدوليه
السابق الى البستان همم هذه الازمه
الجديده ما حدود ارتباطها
بملفات ربما دوليه اخرى بانها ازمه محليه
بحثه
هذا الامر لديه بعد محلي وجيرو سياسي عالم
لاينا مثل هذه الازمه من قبل عندما كنت
اعمل في كوسوفي
رئيسا للبعثه في قصبه في عام 2011 كان
لدينا مثل هذه الازمه في الشمال حيث كان
هنالك توتر بين شرطه قصبه بين الصلب في
الشمال وقد وضعوا ايضا عائقا في الطريق
وقد استمرت لاشهر حتى تمكنت قوات النيتهم
واخيرا من اقناع بازالتها لانها مثل هذا
الامر يحدث من قبل هذا جزء منه هو محلي
والجزء الاخير تم رايناه من في السابق ما
هو جديد انه ياتي في سياق الاعتداء الروسي
على اوكرانيا روسيا وصربيا هم شوارك
وصربيا تدعم روسيا في الكثير من المجالات
وروسيا ايضا همم
مناطق البلق وصربيا تصور وتتاصرف مثل
روسيا وفي منطقه البلقان وتعتبر كوسوفو
على انها دوله غير حقيقيه وتعتبر ايضا همم
جبل الاسود همم
البوسنه والهرسك على انها دول غير حقيقيه
كممثل راي روسيا
ما دلاله ان يطلب الرئيس من قائد الجيش ان
يتوجه نحو همم الحدود مع كوسوفو تحدث طبعا
الرئيس الصردي
نعم نعم هذا سؤال في محل السبب هو ان رئيس
السردين مهتم بالتصعيد وليس التهجئه او
التاكيد فان رئيس صربي
ونظرائه في تركيا رئيس الوزراء الكويتيهم
يعرفون ان النيته هو الذي هو المسؤول عن
الامن في كسفه وخاصه في هذا الشمال
المتوتر بالنسبه للرئيس للقيام بذلك الامر
وارسال رئيس
الى المناطق الحدوديه هذه حركه استفزازيه
وتهدفه الى استعراض القوه والتخويف لكن في
نهايه المطاف
الرئيس همم السردي حاضر ما حاول الدخول
الى قصبه سيكون هنالك تصادم مباشر مع
الناتو وهذه امر لا لن تربحه تربيه في
النهايه حتى لو كان ربما هنالك نجاح مؤقت
لكنه لن ينجح في نهايه المطاف اننيت لن
يسمح بهذا الامر لكنه الوضع متوتر وعلينا
ان نعرف ان الامر لن يتطلب اكثر من حادثه
بسيطه في البلقان مثل كوسوفي
لتصعيد بالاستمرار اذا ما قتل اي شخص او
الجارحه في اي اقتتال او اطلاق نار همم
شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن الدكتور ادوارد
جوزيف المدير التنفيذي لمعهد الشؤون
الدوليه والمبعوث الامريكي السابق الى
البوسنه
نهايه الحصاد لهذه الليله شكرا على حسن
المتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]